>> WHO DO YOU WANT TO SEE RUN?
>> WE WILL HAVE 30 OR 40 GREAT
CANDIDATES RUNNING FOR
CANDIDATE.
>> THAT A LOT.
40 CANDIDATES?
>> THERE ARE A LOT OF U.S.
SENATORS TALKING ABOUT IT, A LOT
OF GOVERNORS COME A LOT OF
PEOPLE OUTSIDE OF POLITICS.
I THINK WE WILL HAVE A BIG FIEL
FIELD.
>> Laura: AND YOU THOUGHT THE
G.O.P. FIELD WAS BIG IN 2016.
30 OR 40 PEOPLE.
WOW.
LOOK AT THESE RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS.
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO EMBRACE
BETO O'ROURKE MANIA, OLD
JOE BIDEN IS EMERGING TO SAY,
WEIGHT AND AMTRAK MINUTE HERE, I
THINK I AM THE MOST QUALIFIED
PERSON IN THE COUNTRY TO BE
PRESIDENT, HE SAID.
THERE IS A NEW TWIST ON ALL OF
THIS TONIGHT.
JUST HOURS AGO IT WAS REPORTED
THAT BETO O'ROURKE SECRETLY MET
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA, WHO IS
SAID TO BE VERY EXCITED ABOUT
HIS POTENTIAL CANDIDACY.
HOW BRUISING WILL A JOE BIDEN
JOE BIDEN-BETO O'ROURKE PRIMARY
BE?
HERE TO DEBATE, FORMER 2016
TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER, AND
POLITICAL ANALYST, COHOST OF
"THE FIVE," OBAMA'S OLD STAFF
SEEMS TO BE PREPPING AN INSTANT
PLUG AND PLAY FOR O'ROURKE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> NOT QUITE, YOU'VE GOT TO WIN
SOMETHING.
IF HE THINKS THE IDEA THAT BETO
O'ROURKE DID NOT WIN VERSUS TED
CRUZ IN TEXAS MEANS THAT HE
SHOULDN'T BE A CONTENDER HERE.
HE HAS GOT TO PROVE THAT HE CAN
BE A WINNER.
BUT I SEE LOTS OF OBAMA PEOPLE,
TO YOUR POINT, LAURA, SAYING
HEY, WE HAVEN'T SEEN EXCITEMENT,
THIS KIND OF CHARISMA, THIS KIND
OF YOUNG PEOPLE ATTRACTED TO A
CANDIDATE SINCE 2008, AND THAT
IS BARACK OBAMA.
AND BY THE WAY, IN IOWA, THEY
HAVE JUST DONE A SURVEY AND IT
TURNS OUT THAT MOST IOWA
DEMOCRATS SAY THEY WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A YOUNG, ENERGETIC NEW FACE
ON THE SCENE.
AND I DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANYONE WHO FITS THAT BILL BETTER
THAN BETO O'ROURKE.
>> Laura: BUT OF COURSE, THE
OLD VICE PRESIDENT!
JOE BIDEN CLEARLY ISN'T FEELING
THE LOVE HERE.
HE IS PRETTY EXPERIENCED.
HE WAS VICE PRESIDENT FOR EIGHT
YEARS, AND ROBERT PRENTICE DOES
THE SHIRT SLEEVE THING KIND OF
LIKE OBAMA USED TODAY.
A JUMP ON STAGE, HE IS YOUNG AND
ENERGETIC, LOVED BY A LOT OF
DEMOCRATS.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
IT.
SOMEONE WHO HAS NEVER WON A BIG
POSITION, LOOKS LIKE THE MOJO
AND THE ENERGY IS MOVING TO HIM.
NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE IT.
>> IT LOOKS LIKE RAGING BULL, "I
COULD HAVE BEEN A CONTENDER."
NEXT THING, TWO FAILED
CANDIDATES, BETO O'ROURKE WILL
BE ONE OF TWO LOSERS WHO WILL
RUN WHEN WE HAVE AN
"EXPERIENCED" CANDIDATE LIKE
JOE BIDEN.
EXPERIENCED MEANS OLD TO THE
AVERAGE CANDIDATE.
THEY ARE BOTH IN THEIR
MID-70s, AND THEN WE GOT
ELIZABETH WARREN AND KAMALA
HARRIS, AND ALL THESE OTHERS WHO
CAN'T GET OUT OF THEIR OWN WAY
WHO WANT TO RUN TO THE FAR LEFT,
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE GOING TO
NOMINATE A VERY LIBERAL
PROGRESSIVE WHO DONALD TRUMP IS
GOING TO WALK ALL OVER.
>> Laura: THERE WAS ANOTHER
GUY WHO RAN AND HASN'T WON
ANYTHING, DONALD TRUMP.
HE NEVER WON ANYTHING, A
POLITICAL OFFENSE, AND HE WON
THE PRESIDENCY.
>> TRUMP IS UP IN HIS 70s,
JOE BIDEN IS HIGHLY EXPERIENCED.
WHEN JOE BIDEN SAYS HE IS THE
MOST QUALIFIED, IT REMINDS ME OF
GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
A VERY QUALIFIED, LOTS OF
EXPERIENCE.
YOU CANNOT ARGUE WITH JOE BIDEN
JOE BIDEN'S MANY YEARS IN THE
SENATE AND ALSO AS THE HEAD OF
THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> Laura: THEY DON'T WANT
BIDEN!
THEY WANT TO BETO.
BIDEN 25, BERNIE SANDERS 13,
HILLARY CLINTON, 13, BETO
O'ROURKE 9%.
I DON'T THINK ANY OF THAT MEANS
ANYTHING RIGHT NOW BECAUSE I'M
TELLING YOU, ALTHOUGH OBAMA IS
MEETING -- HE HAS MET WITH
BERNIE SANDERS, HE HAS MET WITH
ELIZABETH WARREN, AND SPEAKING
OF PEOPLE WHO LIKE TO PULL DOWN
STATUES IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT, MITCHELL ANDREW.
OBAMA FOLKS AND THE FORMER
PRESIDENT HIMSELF, THEY ARE KIND
OF RUNNING OUT OF PATIENCE WITH
TRUMP.
OBAMA IS LIKE, LET ME SHOW YOU
HOW IT'S DONE, AND BETO IS KIND
OF THE, AS HE IS DESCRIBED, AS
THE "WHITE OBAMA."
THEY ARE DESCRIBING HIM THAT
WAY.
>> LOOK, OBAMA HAS SEEN ALL OF
HIS SIGNATURE POLICIES REVERSED
UNDER THIS PRESIDENT.
HE HAS SEEN THE ECONOMY EXPLODE,
HE HAS SEEN THE MAGICIAN THAT HE
CLAIMED IT DIDN'T EXIST WHICH IS
DONALD TRUMP, BRINGS JOBS BACK
TO THIS COUNTRY.
HE HAS SEEN THIS PRESIDENT
RENEGOTIATE BAD TRADE DEALS AND
HE WANTS ANYBODY WHO CAN
CHALLENGE HIM.
THE PROBLEM IS, IN THE 2016
ELECTION, WE HAD THE ADULT
DEBATES AND THE CHILDREN DEBATES
WHICH WERE TWO SEPARATE STAGES.
NOW WE ARE GOING TO HAVE THE
GERIATRICS DEBATE, THE LOSERS
DEBATE, AND EVERYBODY ELSE ON
THE STAGE.
IT'S AMAZING.
30 PEOPLE, YOU'VE GOT TO BE
KIDDING ME!
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I WANT TO GET YOUR THOUGHTS ON
SOMETHING ELSE, BECAUSE TONIGHT
WE ARE MOURNING THE PASSING OF A
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN THAT NEVER
GOT OFF THE GROUND.
MICHAEL AVENATTI ANNOUNCING ON
TWITTER THAT HE WILL NOT RUN IN
2020.
COULD WE POSSIBLY GET THE PORN
STAR ATTORNEY TO CONCEDE?
>> ONLY IF WE WANT TO TICKLE YOU
AND COREY, BECAUSE YOU GUYS
WOULD HAVE A FIELD DAY TALKING
ABOUT HIM.
AND STORMY DANIELS AND ALL OF
THAT.
I THINK STORMY REMAINS ON THE
SCENE IS KRYPTONITE TO TRUMP,
BUT YOU GUYS AS POLITICAL PEOPLE
WITHIN, HOW RIDICULOUS.
I MUST SAY, HE DOES REVEAL AN
INSTINCT ON THE DEMOCRATIC PART
WHICH IS THEY WANT SOMEONE WHO
WOULD GO TOE-TO-TOE SLUGGING IT
OUT WITH THE HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMP,
TRUMP.
SO MICHAEL AVENATTI SAYS THAT IS
WHAT HE WILL DO.
THE OTHER PEOPLE HE SAYS, THEY
ARE WIMPS, THEY ARE GOING TO GET
RUN OVER BY THE BIG HEAVYWEIGHT
DONALD TRUMP.
BUT I THINK YOU ARE GOING TO
FIND THAT THE DEMOCRATS HAVE A
BIG APPETITE FOR SOMEBODY WHO IS
A FIGHTER, BUT TO ME, MICHAEL
AVENATTI HAS JUST TOO MANY
DEFICITS GOING IN.
HE IS TOO MUCH OF A TARGET FOR
YOU GUYS.
>> Laura: WE TALKED ABOUT, YOU
NEED A FIGHTER IN 2020.
WEAK AT THAT, BUT YOU ALSO NEED
SOMEONE WHO COMES WITH SOME
LEVEL, I THINK, OF GRAVITAS AND
EXPERIENCE.
WHO KNOWS WHERE WE WILL BE IN
TWO YEARS IN THE ECONOMY,
CERTAINLY HOPE IT'S DOING WELL,
BUT YOU'RE GOING UP AGAINST
SOMEBODY WHO HAS BEEN THROUGH
THE MEAT GRINDER OF POLITICS
OVER THE LAST SIX YEARS.
AND THAT'S NOT EASY.
I DON'T CARE IF YOU ARE YOUNG
AND ENERGETIC AND GOOD LOOKING.
YOU ARE FROM TEXAS AND YOU HAVE
A COOL NAME, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
YOU HAVE THE POLITICAL TALENT OF
BARACK OBAMA.
HE HAD AN ENORMOUS RAW POLITICAL
TALENT, OBAMA DID.
AND WE WILL SEE WHETHER BETO
DOES.
COREY, QUICK CLOSE IT OUT.
>> I AGREE, I DON'T THINK ANYONE